alice thomas et jean baptiste qui ont
quand on les voit comme ça quand on les
écoute qui ont trois personnalités très
différent tu les as trouvé tout de suite
casting c'était évident pour toi on en a
vu pas mal
or ce que j'aime bien moi c'est un avoir
une discussion avec eux et généralement
ce que je leur demande c'est de raconter
une histoire qui appartient à l'univers
du film mais qui est une histoire
personnelle
donc là je me souviens je crois je leur
avais demandé si c'était des personnages
qui ressemblait aux acteurs de la
coopération à de la crème de la crème
donc est ce qu'il avait fait des
conneries à l'école et si oui lesquelles
donc en même temps ça ça permet tout
c'est une discussion assez marrante et
puis moi je vois travers leur
personnalité qui pourront donner au
personnage et l'idée est donc de trouver
des acteurs qui ressemble au personnage
est la deuxième étape et nous avec le
scénariste de nous rapprocher des
acteurs
au début tu speed un peu après tu
ralenti le rythme et à la fin des seuils
de
et et sai kung carte plus le gag de
champagne qu'est ce que tu veux dire un
banquet bonne nuit
tu vois ces zones est et le temps qu'on
capte que tu captes parce qu'il est en
train d'exciter voix on n'a pas du tout
touché au texte on a eu pas mal de
répétition avec kim et noé et tous les
cinq scénaristes rennes où est le
scénariste et on a fait un peu de
patience et de réalisation on a fait des
exercices sur des fautes si l'exercice
est par exemple jeu du sumo on est deux
à chaque fois et il y en a un qui cache
un un bout de tissu a dans son pantalon
et le but c'est d'essayer
d'impressionner l'autre début et de
faire un énorme cri et ensuite on doit
essayer de pécho le foulard dans le
pantalon d'autres ces trucs qu'on
comprenait pas du tout au départ au
zénith qu'est ce qui en fait il était
chez moi ils mettaient de la techno
berlinoise ils nous faisaient danser
nous écrier des trucs qu'on disait mais
où ça va et en fait ça nous a vraiment
aidés à être soudé et à la fin on était
vraiment une pote ça nous a dit vous
êtes désinhibé on n'est plus taboue
enfin du coup sur le plateau ça permet
aussi une certaine aisance me faisait
aller plus loin quand on avait monté pas
encore eu tellement bien que je pense
qu'à ce jour
ça qu'on a fait deux mois de répèt où on
se voyait quasiment tous les jours et
avec des impros des choses comme ça dit
des jeux et ça met beaucoup d'impro
aussi jamais vraiment avec le texte d un
pro qui tourne autour de situations du
film et qui nourrissent le film et qui
nourrissent les personnages se sont
retrouvés la faim moi j'ai vraiment
trouvé le personnage
à ce moment là dedans s'est répèté très
naturellement bon ok c'est d'accord
qu'un beau mec c'est pas beau c'est la
série j ai beau football
ensuite les eaux calmes et riche il a
plus de chance de se marier une belle
feinte tout âge sita